on sait que vous vous avez choisi de
fermer votre station exactement pourquoi
c'est en protestation ne pouvais plus
si vous voulez c'est compliqué parce que
quand le prix à peu près correct on va
dire un euro cinquante mais il ya ça
très très longtemps
on a commencé à monter petit à petit un
heureux 69 70 et là on a on s'est fait
on s'est fait massacrer parce que des
gens c'est pour ça que je suis là pour
expliquer justement parce que les gens
comprennent pas en fait le prix du
carburant augmente c'est de notre faute
il paraît que vous faite insulter aussi
beaucoup souvent assez sarkozy a
réactivé il ya pas des petits mots qui
sont pas très sympas triste mais ça
n'est pas agréable bien laver 10 euros
parce qu'il va me ruiner me disais pas
de votre faute non voilà non est ce que
c'est vrai que lily a énormément de deux
patrons de stations service qui qui ne
disent tout fait insulter voilà alors et
les regards du vandalisme on se pince
hulpe et on nous parle même plus c'est
vrai qu'on arrive on nous jette parfois
l'argent comme ça rigole parce qu'on est
temps qu'on prend sur le désarroi des
automobilistes mais sachez que ça n'est
pas de la faute des patrons de stations
service les bobines n'y sont pour rien
et donc c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
pour vous et je vous ai sentis voilà je
vous ai senti triste de ce qui se
passait avant tout à fait parce que nous
ça fait maintenant pratiquement 25 26
ans que je tiens ce garage avec cette
station il est hors de question que je
ferme définitivement sûr puisque je les
achetais avec et puis c'est un lien
social je vous expliquerai tout à leur
plein de personnes viennent au garage
parce que on a une station service une
grande surface c'est pour ça que je suis
content d'avoir je ne connaissais pas
je ne le connaissais pas du tout je
l'avais jamais vu pour l'instant il n'a
pas marqué aimable il n'a rien marqué en
ce moment puisque je le connaissais pas
pourtant un en principe les ministres on
les connaît mais en mode campagne et le
temps il est venu depuis les venues nous
voir souvent à venir car tous les jours
je travaille jusqu'à 8h30 9h soit
repensé à qui on est dans une catégorie
de gens qui travaillent énormément chez
nous en haute loire partout dans toute
la france je veux pas dire qu'il n'ya
que la haute-loire mais je trouve que
c'est compliqué et c'est pour ça que je
suis très content d'être en face bien
ministre a déjà ces camps pour un gros
de sa part d'être venu ce soir ne se
parlait d'un sujet tient en ce moment
est très très épineux donc merci
jean baptiste du baril la première
question qu'on se pose est que les
français se posent ainsi nous regardent
ce soir est ce que les prix de l'essence
ont baissé mais vont baisser la semaine
prochaine mais la récession se dit les
choses c'est qu'on vit une époque dans
lequel le prix du pétrole au sens large
et longue du gasoil du simple on va
rester au pour plusieurs raisons est-ce
qu'on peut expliquer aux français parce
que on parle moi je comprends rien donc
voilà on va dire voilà je comprends rire
ce qui se passe on parle à chaque fois
on parle du prix du baril du pétrole
briques je vous dis nous y en a pleins
ils sont devant moi je vois parfois je
regarde les infos et ils disent y parle
du prix du baril je sors de là je ne
comprends rien et je ne sais pas je ne
saurai jamais vous dire pourquoi le prix
à la pompe et est élevée derrière est-ce
que simplement monsieur ministre pouvez
nous expliquer expliquer une personne
qui nous regardent ce qui se passe et ce
qu'on nous explique qu'on comprend pas
ce qui se passe vraiment simplement pour
le faire super schématiquement le
pétrole on n'en produit pas en france
c'est ça donc on importe essentiellement
le moyen-orient quelques autres pays
l'essentiel du prix que vous payez à la
pompe c'est le prix des matières
premières et au dessus à des taxes on en
parlera et la taxe sur les produits
pétroliers et la tva l'essentiel de ce
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui enfin
l'augmentation des prix ces deux
éléments d'abord on a une forte demande
de pétrole toutes les économies du monde
reparte notamment la chine fait toutes
les économies du monde en parle et
demande beaucoup de pétrole ont fait la
transition vers d'autres énergies donc
on investit moins de pétrole et ça ça
crée déjà de toute façon en effet un peu
inflationniste à long terme et deuxième
élément le crès la crise ukrainienne
donc elles nous touchent la crise alors
ça c'est celle à la russie qui nous
approvisionnent en pétrole est pour
partie mais en fait ce qui se passe
c'est que aujourd'hui y compris les
acheteurs européens n'y a pas de pénurie
aujourd'hui la russie produit du pétrole
y a pas de pénurie nulle part dans le
monde mais les acheteurs sur le marché
sont réticents de toute façon acheter du
pétrole russe donc ça sacré en fait le
surcoût qu'on a vu récemment donc pour
tous ces éléments on a une inflation qui
est assez forte
si on vous dit la vérité cette inflation
le prix du pétrole va rester durablement
ou dans les prochaines années c'est ce
que dit tout aujourd'hui donc on a deux
actions à faire la question que je pose
de jean baptiste si on prend variante 2
euros litre à la pompe quel est ce
pourcentage de ce que coûtent les
matières premières
des pourcentages des taxes voilà mais si
on prend par exemple un 15 2 euros ou 1
50 on a à peu près 90 centimes de
matières premières surtout la production
enfin la pointe sur 2 euros parce que
c'est très simple mais mettons
maintenant un gros 1 euros en or en face
entre moitié-moitié sim accord mais
c'est moitié pour la production qu'à
vous vous faites l'extraction du pétrole
lorsque vous avez le transport la
distribution auxerre noise tout ça c'est
assez c'est plutôt 16 20 centimes
d'euros d'accords et au dessus vous avez
les taxes 60 centimes et de l'intérieur
donc voilà avait un sentiment que je
sais ce que vous allez me dire vous
allez enlever en ce moment le vous allez
baisser les taxes et la tva non on va ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va rembourser
les stations service anouk les 15
centimes que le premier ministre a
annoncé ce qu'on va faire très
concrètement pour faire baisser les prix
du pétrole les prix de l'essence à la
pompe de man vient clore et partout en
france c'est que l'état prend en charge
15 centimes d'euros d'accords et
certains pétroliers comme total qui ont
des moyens prennent en charge 10
centimes d'euro et moi je le dis c'est
une chance aussi on ne dit jamais ça
mais c'est une chance d'avoir des grands
groupes de l'énergie en france parce
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens qui
tapent sur total bien sûr mais je le
comprends parce que c'est un groupe qui
est qui est évidemment a du succès mais
il ya cinq ou six grands groupes
mondiaux du pétrole et du gaz dans le
monde on en a un et six ans les stations
service en france total ses 2600
stations sur les 10000 un sur dix 11
mille stations donc c'est quand même un
quart des stations et c'est parce qu'on
arrive à faire jouer aussi la solidarité
de total en l'occurrence un corps qu'on
arrive à baisser de 15 centièmes pour
l'état et de 10 centimes pour total donc
cesser cette vos efforts conjugués si
vous voulez concret qui prévalait à
paris pour que olivier sont conquises
lundi eh ben je pouvoir afficher ce prix
là à pompe je vous allez baissé de 25
centimes d'euro pour être concret lundi
l'a20 aujourd'hui il ya dessus
cela de près et effectivement informe
carats vous dites n'importe quoi pour
toi olivier sur un litre de carburant et
comment je viens de relire de carburant
il ya la tva il ya là pis c et e on est
d'accord c'est ce que j'ai expliqué oui
mais on est à 60 grosso modo salle st
gelais 60 45 % grosso modo de taxes de
taxes ce qui est oscar when 65
production à la cause matière de
réduction des coûts fait votre plein
avec combien au niveau monnaie euro ça
vous coûte quoi un plein de voitures
grosso modo 50 face est à peu près moi
je 58 de mon véhicule 2-0 s'emballe à
les 60 litres c'est bien parce que
j'avais préparé ça comme il faut on va
dire 60 litres donc vous vous mettez à
peu près 120 euros à 11 euros on est
d'accord vous savez combien je gagne
vous savez combien les ponts qu'elle
cède en france pas moi quelques le nord
le sud l'est elle que centimes par les
échos mais je gagne non quelques
centimes par l'iace que vous savez
badiou s'agirait généré 5 centimes par
litre x x 6 6 6 et
2,04 centimes hors taxes
donc sur ce qu'on sait quoi votre marge
du coup à 0 aux lions de la drogue et
des 3 euros
0,04 centime d'euros toutes c'est à dire
ce qui se passe que vous dites qu'ils
étaient totalement sur chaque point
gagné 3 toutes les taxes sont prévues
vous les avez voté au parlement vous le
savez tout a été prévu donc à un moment
ou un autre dès l'instant où vous avez
voté au parlement la taxe la tei cpe
vous pouvez plus la bouger le problème
puisque vous n'avez pas prévu c'est que
vous étiez vraiment limite que le gasoil
ou que le pétrole augmente avec le baril
ça augmente énormément et le problème
c'est que ce n'est pas la tâche et c'est
71e et son fixe temps des whips fx tout
à fait mais dès l'instant où le
carburant augmente la tva augmente tout
augmenté pour une petite partie fin à ce
débat mais j'étais un événement qui nous
fait très très mal nous les travailleurs
on va dire on bosse du matin jusqu'au
soir on cherche pas comprendre on défend
notre entreprise et on se bat vous nous
mettez un grand coup de pelle à neige
c'est à dire vous savez un grand coup de
pelle à neige derrière les oreilles et
après il ya quelqu un ministre ou le
premier ministre qui nous un peu pommade
c'est à dire qui nous met un petit peu
de pommade histoire de dire vous avez
pris un coup de pelle mais c'est pas
grave vous inquiétez pas on va vous
enlevez 15 centimes est juste il ya une
chose que j'ai pas aimé il ya une chose
qu'il m'a aimée sur le journal hier j'ai
regardé parce que hier soir j'ai juste
un petit coup d'oeil un peu partout
regardiez paraît donc même si j'ai
regardé les marine le pen est vraiment
vous avez fait quelque chose
d'extraordinaire sur cette émission
franche et olivier
minne marine le pen oui mais également
sa éclaircissons son visage qui est
d'habitude assez serré donc j'ai trouvé
ça c'est juste une parente de la
déchirure je vous annonce que vous
regardez sur semblait bien sûr fait
jonction a6 a10 et très très très sympa
et donc j'en étais ou au niveau du
carburant si vous voulez qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait hier vous avez vous
quelque chose à dire sur le journal j'ai
vu monsieur le premier ministre que j'ai
invité d'ailleurs à ma station j'ai
envoyé une petite vidéo que j'ai envoyée
pour qu'ils puissent venir le premier va
vite parce que je pense que le 1er avril
il mettait sur le journal que en fait
pourquoi il faisait le 1er avril zhou
lire pourquoi pas c'est un gros poisson
mon avis c'est un gros poisson ce qui
nous arrive c'est vraiment un gros gros
poisson c'est à dire qu'il est tellement
gros à mon avis tiendra pas dans le dos
de monsieur castex parce que ce qu'il
fait c'est qu'en fait ils nous passent
de potes pommade ils nous passent 15
centimes et puis après il dit que les
pétroliers jauron un peu le jeu et non
un jour à un peu le jeu c'est à dire que
les pétroliers plus nos ça fait 5
centimes dans 15 puis 5 lui pense que ça
va faire valais la grande distribution
dans l'es21 de notre marge encore à 0 0
4 centime d'euro savez quand je le fais
sur mon ordinateur sur le pupitre je le
change mais je le change en france c'est
à dire je mets 0,45 type de frein je
fais comme les anciens j'ai rien contre
les anciens c'est super mais je mets 0 4
centime que j'ai l'impression de gagner
un peu plus et après quand je traduis un
neuro ça me fait 0-0 400e d'euros c'est
à dire 5 centimes d'euros à peu près ttc
est ce que vous vous imaginez faire
tourner vers une boutique faire tourner
les machines payer l'électricité puisque
j'ai un 24 24 pour 0 0 4 centime d'euro
c'est à dire je vends jamais ni ma
machine à calculer de mon garage
d'accord parce que j'ai dit si tu filmes
en amène une elle fera peut-être façon
si jamais
voilà je fais 15 mille litres on imagine
jours un mois excusez-moi quinze mille
litres moi je multiplie sa part 0 0 4
centime d'euro mais 600 euros est ce que
vous payez un mi temps une caissière qui
est là pour est ce que vous payez quinze
mille litres 600 euros hors taxes est ce
que vous pouvez dire comment je peux
gagner ma vie comment l'ensemble parce
que je suis pas la peau tous les
pompistes de france à vous vous êtes
ministre moi je suis pompiste c'est
génial ça c'est super de boulot parfait
mais seulement moi j'ai pris un
ternissement l'erythrée longtemps parce
que je travaillais avec mes matches
travailler avec plein de choses et ce
qui se passe c'est gagner 600 euros sur
un mois ci ont fait quinze mille litres
je vous promets c'est compliqué donc je
m'attendais à ce que l'état fasse
quelque chose de plus important vraiment
beaucoup plus important à dire de dire
on va limiter les taxes il ya monsieur
mélenchon ne suis pas du tout avec
monsieur mélenchon mais qui dit il faut
geler le prix du carburant en fait chez
nous qu est ce qui nous qu'est ce qui
nous gêne c'est le gaz
c'est l'électricité et c'est le
carburant pourquoi j'ai
pris de façon à avoir quelque chose de
cohérent et que le nord le sud paye de
la même chose parce que pourquoi moi je
vends mon carburant et pourquoi la
grande surface d'à côté la 20 20 30
centimes je suis leclerc qui apparaît la
dernière fois je suis désolé il a parlé
je vous rapporte pourquoi il a parlé
pourquoi c'est pas vous qui avez parlé
alors
ministre du transport ne répondra jamais
allé au g20 marque
mais rapidement d'abord quand on se
regarde ce qu'il faut toujours un peu se
comparer y a pas un pays en europe qui
fait plus que nous sur le contrôle des
prix de l'énergie on a contrôlé le prix
du gaz on limite la hausse de
l'électricité à les voir en italie en
espagne sur le gaz par exemple si on
n'avait pas contrôler les prix du gaz et
tout le monde paye son chauffage
engageant tout cas beaucoup on aurait
les français auraient payé en moyenne
400 euros de plus par an donc on n'avait
pas un pays en europe qui a fait plus
que nous premiers éléments nous aimer le
mans quand vous dites les taxes d'abord
les taxes sur l'essence le gasoil sont
gelés depuis 2018 ça a été de le grand
sujet avec le gilet jaune elles sont
jolies et après si on dit la vérité
c'est pas vrai c'est 6 puis j'ai laissé
lui non plus privé a immédiatement mais
pas la télé peut aller geler la tax day
ces précieuses d'accord et à la fin de
la fin les taxes la tva c'est notre
budget commun donc si on raisonne il
faut raisonner court terme moyen terme
si on raisonne court terme moi je
comprends parfaitement que les
automobilistes j'en suis un les
pompistes bref l'ensemble des personnes
qui sont touchées par l'augmentation du
prix du pétrole encore une fois qui est
très largement dû parce qu'on ne produit
pas de pétrole qu'on ne maîtrise pas
cette énergie soit énervé mais la vérité
elle est double d'abord un s'est amené à
être durable donc le la vraie solution à
moyen terme se sont désengagés des décès
je comprends ça votre business ça peut
être dur à entendre mais à voir se
désengager collectivement de ce qu'on ne
produit pas c'est à dire les produits
qu'elle y fait trop lié et la crise en
russie en ukraine exacerbe encore un
autre débat ça et le deuxième débat mais
c'est là où je vous renvoie fait un peu
de politique le deuxième débat c'est que
il n'ya pas deux c'est pas une cagnotte
la tva et les taxes c'est notre budget
commun c'est notre compte commun à tous
c'est ce qui nous permet de payer la
santé les hôpitaux les écoles etc etc
donc il faut faire le raisonnement
jusqu'au bout et pas rire sur les aides
fournies là dessus pas de preuve ni
vraiment là-dessus sur les aides là vous
parlez des aides sur les 15 centimes
d'euro pour baisser le prix l'essence
mais les aides qu'on a consenti à tous à
tous entrepreneur l'épée jeu est prêt et
je pense que vous avez pu en bénéficier
aussi pour résister pendant la crise
aussi deux fois s'il faut aussi un peu
voilà il faut tout dire mais c'est
toujours un gouvernement soporifique si
vous voulez votre discours il est lé
euros c'est pas ce qu'on pourrait
finalement
la fameuse taxe si vous voulez comme
vous donnez vous savez combien le
rapporte à l'état mais par an cumulée
ses 45 milliards d'euros mais aussi bien
qu elle mais non non la tei c'est
18 milliards d'euros ses talents de
chamakh c'est très bien c'est pour aucun
des médias pour les jaunes 15 centimes
les automobilistes vont prendre ça va
lui coûter 2 milliards d'après ce que je
comprends c'est dans ce squat de 3
milliards parce que le cds grec saxe il
faut baisser les taxes mais de toute
façon les taxes c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on se donne comme budget pour nous
même sexe et lieu d'abord que tu débat
avec vous mais vous vous prenez des
taxes donc tout à l'heure vous avez été
faux dans ce que vous avez dit c'est 70%
à peu près de taxes on va dire vous avez
à peu près 20% au niveau donc du
pétrolier est à peu près du produit brut
et nous avez 0,0 voilà ce que c'est les
miettes le problème c'est qu'on voudrait
passer au dessus pourquoi pas mettre le
prix toute l'année au même prix
exactement pareil on imagine que je
dirais qu'avant de l'essence que vous
avez dit que la grande sur mathieu
d'abord vous voulez réagir oui parce que
je trouve ça un peu dégueulasse que je
comprends ce que c'est mais aux états
unis le prix de l'essence c'est le tiers
du prix de l'essence en france donc
j'aimerais juste ça va alors je
comprendrais mais ce que dit monsieur le
ministre ok mais grâce à la taxe en
france eh ben on paye la sécu et tous
avaient cessé mais pourquoi c'est au
pompiste parce qu aux etats unis le
tennier désistement et non aux états
unis l'hôpital c'est vous qui payez une
crèche
ouais c'est juste que l'acteur mais de
quoi dire je ris coop l'argent et je
leur distribuer à l'état voilà voilà
c'est ni plus ni moi je suis un trésor
public il va il va répondre monsieur lui
nice là dessus sur ce qu'a dit le malin
mais ça reste au club louis né aux états
unis d'un tiers ouais c c c c
c'est un tir le nez en france expliqué
d'abord deux choses les états unis les
produits du pétrole en gaz et d'user
mais les noms au courant vous avez un
enfant leur réseau ni ses quarante mille
dollars par an la crèche c'est pareil
chacun dépose enfin le modèle américain
c'est que vous gagnez plus ne vous êtes
un peu tout seul et que si vous avez les
moyens de vous payer les services
publics eh ben vous voulez payer si vous
n'avez pas les moyens ou ne les payez
pas le modèle français il est différent
il est socialisé ça veut dire qu'en gros
chacun ici en tout cas la majorité des
personnes autour du plateau payent des
impôts on paye des impôts pour financer
nos services publics ce qui fait que
quand vous avez vous soigner vous payer
un euro de 0 voit rien ces dix modèles
politiques complètement différent j'ai
voté chaque année olivier thomas disait
il ya un instant jean luc mélenchon a
proposé de geler le prix de l'essence
est ce que c'est possible ça ou est ce
que c'est une mesure topic la vérité
c'est que aujourd'hui si vous jouez donc
il ya une partie et 60 centimes son jeu
les mêmes et si vous gelez imaginons la
tva même si vous réduisez la tva à zéro
ce qui augmente si le prix de la matière
première donc ce qu'on n'augmente pas en
voie d'accord à ce moment il est là il
est en janvier li mais de combien sera
durable était agacé parce qu'ils
essaient de le débat je suis d'accord
avec vous s'il vous dire je suis là que
ça va durer ça va durer pour les raisons
que j'ai expliqué aujourd'hui on
désinvesti le monde désinvesti audi
d'énergie le gouvernement s'est fait mal
dans le monde entier s de la pommade del
monte donc le prix des matières
premières va augmenter et par ailleurs
tout le monde consomme beaucoup de
personnes aujourd'hui sachez que c'est
si j'essaie d'en venir même si on met à
les taxer 0 blême si on mettait les
taxes à 0 on serait plus financer nos
services publics pas d'accord et en plus
ça continuerait probablement une bonne
dix heures par jour et gagner 600 euros
par mois sans trop parfaitement ça je
veux pas du tout mettre en cause à bord
les ainsi été qu'il fut miss évidemment
je suis comptable et je suis désolé le
pire le pire c'est que edouard leclerc a
parlé à la télé et ce n'était pas à lui
à parler pour moi c'est à vous a parlé
pour on va dire la responsabilité de
ceux de ce mouvement c'est vous c'est le
ministre des transports je suis désolé
c'est pas edouard leclerc à nous dire le
carburant la décennie suivante est ce
que vous connaissez bien visuel non mes
options mais à un moment ou un autre
c'est votre job devant tous les français
c'est votre job parce qu'on a fait
j'étais à 25 centimes cieux leclerc
alary l'antenne en disant que ça allait
descendre de 35 centimes d'euro parce
qu'en fait techniquement grosso modo on
va voir il a dit la raison d'ailleurs il
l'a dit parce qu'ils passent que la
vérité c'est que on a eu une très grosse
augmentation avec le début du conflit
craignant et je vais pas faire de
technique mais hélas pas afin l'euro est
remonté par rapport au dollar et donc ça
a mécaniquement baisser le prix à la
pompe s'est passé donc il a eu raison de
le dire après il a aussi raison de
prendre sa part monsieur leclerc comme
les autres c'est le claé ils gagnent
quand elles mêmes sur l'île à un grand
groupe quand monsieur j'ai très bien mon
carburant prix coûtant et que les gens
passent devant chez moi ils me regardent
et puis dix loteries les fadas et 100
mais voilà il faisait bon coin des yeux
vous dire il a senti
le papier qui va chercher de carburant
tous les samedis avec sa petite voiture
au garage ses petits enfants lui dise
mais tu es fou papy pas pas chercher de
carburant chez lui et a vu combien le 20
25 35 division leclerc mais qu'est ce tu
t'en fous papier par le regarder il va
dire tu sais il n'y a pas que l'argent
dans la vie mais je sais que je suis une
serbe carburant sa vie un mois fruit
mais oui mais je suis donc allé chercher
même s'agit d'amener commune dans les
petites communes parce que vraiment
c'est dur toutes les stations ont
disparu beaucoup beaucoup entre les
mairies réinvestissent 150000 euros pour
acheter une station ils sont fous
maintenant ça marche non parce que moi
si je ferme ma station l'an prochain je
le ferai pas dans les yeux dans les yeux
je le ferai pas parce que vous savez
qu'il ya un grain fêlures la mairie à
rien sinon une station-service commune
ans et ça marche pourquoi ils ont fait
fermer les stations parce que les gens
n'y allez pas parce que les grandes
surfaces en californie s'est beaucoup
démené fientes les concurrences et le
problème c'est qu'après il se retourne
et des stations ont été fermées et
maintenant ils se retrouvent dans des
endroits on est à 30 km d'une station
service et la mairie dit je vais investi
cent cinquante mille euros plusieurs
showrooms station parler là c'est
ridicule par le lendemain du débat c'est
de l'argent pire dans l'est de la
concussion et la grande distribution ces
savoureuses des raisons mais c'est
encore un autre sujet fin c'est le monde
dans lequel on prépare au sujet au début
des années 80 avec 45 initiation service
en gros aujourd'hui à peu près de 10000
parfois ça c'est l'effet de la grande
distribution harris et les faits qu'on
vit de plus en plus dans les grandes
largeurs et le sujet qu'on a et vous
avez tout à fait raison c'est jean
notamment aux zones rurales c'est de
préserver les gens comme vous qui font
du service de proximité et salle les
gens ne comprennent pas parce que le
président 25 centimes ils font mais je
veux dire que j'étais le gros si on bat
pauline confirme le grand père on est
toujours la même station service parce
qu'ils avaient du service parce que les
virages de mon grand père est donc c'est
ça aussi dans le modèle de proximité
qu'ont les gens recherchent en sièges et
en voix claviers barriques dernière
question pour rassurer
voilà olivier de nombreuses personnes
qui nous regarde le prix de l'essence là
donc il va baisser dès lundi là on est à
2 euros à peu près du litre en moyenne
21 75 à peu près à peu près sans casse
avec durable ça mais le sujet non
d'abord les mesures c'est à compter du
1er avril c'est la première brique
s'abaisse un petit peu mais donc c'est
15 centimes effectivement par par l'état
et total fait licencier il s'installe
c'est pas tout l'élan chalon exactement
à peu près un quart des stations et donc
oui ça va ça va ça va baisser savoir en
effet important à la baisse pour le pour
la boue pour le portefeuille la réalité
encore une fois et ils vont chacune soit
un total c'est moins de 6000 habitants
oui tout le monde l'a pas ça oui faut
que ça soit dans une bourgade de -6
d'habitants et vous m'expliquerez
comment fait au total deux fois que j'ai
défendu la mesure précédente à des
injures publiques et le front chaud je
le disais et le comme tout en défendant
lever 15 centimes d'euros et le fonds
sur l'ensemble de régis surtout comment
vous allez faire mal on va rembourser en
l'occurrence les pompistes ou les
metteurs en marché elles avancent de
trésorerie bah c'est le sujet c'est de
suivre notre inde aujourd'hui de régler
si vous venez là c'est pour débattre sur
mes droits je suis parfaitement au
courant d'huchet qui est un sujet
trésorerie donc l'idée c'est d'aller en
bourse et rapidement ce qu'en fait pour
expliquer aux gens donc l'état va
rembourser les pompistes pour le faire
simplement et le pompiste va facturer
les clients c'est simple il ya chez
trésorerie pour le pompiste le temps que
l'état remboursé l'état et ça le
distributeur est ça qu on notera
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on offre à
20 centimes d'euro et
sarkozy 15 centimes passant juste dit
voilà je remettais pas normal
c'est messi mais c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement actuel c'est du grand
n'importe quoi justement ils nous font
mal et on produit pas de pétrole
monsieur mais lequel choisir on a une
production nationale attendez la vérité
la libération du bruit les frontières
durant ces termes duquel and roll
monsieur allez mettons produit un peu
des crises chez john crowley
finissez le canal aussi important en
quelle année le carburant appelait les
tabous très solide un nul ils en
appellent à l'état sont devenus libres
en quelle année d'amateurs baptisé
mariera ne produit pas de pétrole ok ça
mais c'est assez merci les prend pas un
concours mais c'est déjà un sujet quant
à 2012 2013 à un euro explique comment
la france qui s'est jetée sur la date
dans la bonne équipe qui lui doit
consommer à peu près 1 % du pétrole
mondial a un effet au niveau mondial
pour contrôler les prix du pétrole ça
n'existe pas est ce que vous dites là
c'est vous tapez sur l'état qui fait pas
chez je vais vous dire qu'on trouvait le
preneur je vous dirais knicks par
olivier on était à 1 euro 50 il ya 2012
2013 dit rené pasquet béton production
voilà 35 chez magrin captivé passé il a
dit on va essayer d'augmenter de 10
centimes d'euros par an ça fait cinq ans
ça fait 55 50 centimes et de la taxe
carbone pour que les gens comprennent
mais chez d'accord mais il a dit ça
qu'il allait augmenter de 50 centimes
d'euro sur grosso modo cinq ans le
problème ce qui se passe ces quatre
carburant augmente comme ça les taxes
suis ce que je suis mais lui il a fait
ça pour quoi et puis l'année en plus il
a dit je vend 50 centimes pour que les
français changent d'habitude ne roule
plus en gasoil achètent des voitures
essence d'accord donc là je vous disais
voilà leur entrée c'est un billet
d'avion parce que je sais que vous êtes
bien la septième au luxembourg semble en
très haut débit
oui d'accord je tourne et c'est le 1er
mai actions france veut garder
d'environnement de parce que chez nous
on faire sur l'environnement bape est
petit on est en campagne on est en
campagne je vous promets on faire de
notre planète yoroppa aux champignons en
face de mon garage et des mourides à
l'esquissé des mauries leurs carences
des fois j'en ai plein la tête que
quelqu'un me dit vous êtes un voleur je
passe et puis je vais chercher 2 3
mourir au mois de mars à brides c'est à
cette époque là justement mais c'est
génial hein parce que attention on est
bien chez nous on veut personne on est
très très bien et comme on est mais ce
que je voulais dire si vous voulez c'est
qu'à un moment ou un autre je sais plus
où j'en étais la nôtre
on va clôturer très vite parce que je
voudrais savoir odier j'ai une question
à vous poser on est à quelques jours
d'une élection est ce qu'aujourd'hui il
avait trouvé un candidat qui a
qui à vos faveurs oki ou qui ont nagé
l'impressionnant qui a nombreuses
personnes ici qui viennent qui
critiquent le gouvernement qui
critiquent la politique du gouvernement
actuel du président et il ya personne
qui a grâce à leur vue est-ce que vous
un candidat sans nous le dire en jogging
ingère durée y en a pas aucun aucun
aucun mais c'est souvent le carrosse qui
s'occupe pas de nous
moi je suis en haute-loire que je gagne
0 0 4 centime de rouge j'insiste là
dessus c'est une piqûre un surnom c'est
un plaisir de le dire parce que je les
remercie ça c'est un chiffre qui va être
au menu parité 0 0 4 centime d'euro je
le dis à tout le monde 1 004 centimes
d'euro hors taxe le truc est là c'est
que il ya personne qui s'est assis au
bout douane sur une table avec un 10 ans
écoutait qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
plaisir aux français mais est ce qu'on
peut faire plaisir aux chefs
d'entreprise donc aujourd'hui vous allez
vous allez voter qui vous allez voter
vous avez vous abstenir
ça aujourd'hui ne nous dit pas pourriez
vous avez vous abstenir n'ai pas voté
et personne n'y a personne qui mon coeur
si vous voulez je suis un chef
d'entreprise je vais de l'avant ma façon
d'être c'est d'être du côté où emmanuel
macron liberté du tout vous êtes un chef
d'entreprise à un pas du tout vous devez
retrouver la crosse et un banquier la
nuit l'épargnant ne veut pas dire il
faut faire sortir l'argent valérie
pécresse oui mais je suis pas au centre
et ça donc moi je suis je suis plein à
fond le problème c'est que je suis un
patron je crée je veux avancer et le
problème j'ai personnes qui me
représente arrimer les messieurs hier
soir j'adorais ouais voilà j'adorais
marine le pen c'est du sept qui a plus
de dettes non non non on ne traite pas
parce qu'en fait elle est peut-être plus
proche des autres mais un moment où
notre personne n'est capable de nous
dire vous avez des difficultés on va
vous aider parce que c'est bien de cinq
incendiés trouver ce qu il disait madame
tout à l'heure qu'un centime c'est pas
normal que c'était normal argent en fait
c'est pas normal je plais olivier en
tout cas on se retiendra ce chiffre vous
reconnaissez pas dire qu'un pour la
france entière au caire entre 0,03 et
0,07 vous êtes nos taxes et droits 041
olivier on va battre et médecin
jean baptiste et barry branchements aux
olives et c'est quand même courageux de
la part du ministre est venu nous voir
soir parce qu'il savait que ça allait
être un peu voilà ça allait secouer et
olives et vous avez raison bien sûr me
déloger l'équipe du voir ce que c'est
mais c'est que pour sortir la haute
loire c'est compliqué j'ai demandé à
monsieur laurent wauquiez parce que
laurent wauquiez et de mon secteur en
fait ils directeur de président de
région je vais demander de me faire un
métro entre saint paulien et le puits il
a rigolé il dit j'arrive pas déjà à
faire une autoroute entre le puy et
saint-etienne donc je pense que ça va
être compliqué pour que je te fasse à
métro mais non mais je le dis parce
qu'on a des difficultés chez nous vous
pouvez pas vous imaginer
vous avez l'impression vraiment qu on
est en ville et qu'on est à paris qu on
est à lyon non non non dans ses mains
une campagne